visit expressvpn.com and get three extra
months of expressvpn for free
[Applause]
the republican party i disagree with
them on pretty much everything
but what i what i do admire about
republicans is they unapologetically
fight for their agenda
you know they unapologetically fight for
their kind of you know hard right
almost you know white nationalistic
agenda at times especially donald trump
hardline on immigration
you know he's very somebody described
that there was another guy who came on
matt jones who's a democrat from
kentucky and he said something really
really stuck with me
he said that um one thing republicans do
better than democrats
is they let some of like the internal
um fights uh take their course
the democratic party is always trying to
like like stick
its nose in kind of earlier in the um
in the process to try and keep um
progressives or folks who who they think
are
in your mind like unrealistic from like
actually getting the resources necessary
to
um become the the party's nominee in
those races
under the guise of electability but
there's like more to it than
electability and i think he was right i
think i was like wow
so in that way republicans are more like
lower case d democratic because they'll
really just let the will of the people
even if the people choose in some cases
like some freaking loons because there
are some freaking moons like
absolutely that are like peddling
conspiracy theories so while the
republicans kind of unapologetically
fight for their agenda and they fight
for their base
the democrats they they they're always
wanting to moderate their message
[Music]
how's georgia george is great
it really is quite nice um been knocking
on doors doing press
um just doing anything i can to browse
energy
i'm doing an event with high school
democrats um
this week young people love me so
yeah it's been really good i think
reverend warnock wants me in an ad too
which is very flattering thank you
reverend warnock
um uh it's been dynamite but even while
i've been here
you know that we've been working on cash
relief feverishly and i have to say
i think we've had our high water mark
legislative achievement
where you've probably seen if you're
listening to this the stuff that's going
on in congress where
uh it was gridlock uh
no deal was happening and then a group
of bipartisan senators
got together and said hey here's a 908
billion dollar deal wouldn't this be
great
and then everyone's like oh my gosh a
compromise bill but you know what the
compromise bill did not have
in it money for people stimulus checks
cash for people everyone's favorite
thing
about the last cares act economist's
favorite thing
about the last cares act where money in
our hands is the
most important thing so then uh
we sprang into action and now
there is a bipartisan
house bill that says look this thing
needs to include
checks for people stimulus checks cash
and the
co-sponsors of this bill i am so excited
and proud
and if if you are on social media you
should follow these two people because
they really stepped up
lisa blunt rochester uh
democratic congresswoman uh from
delaware
and david mckinley a republican
congressman from west virginia
now think about that that pair
they stepped forward and said look this
is bipartisan everyone wants it
and now dozens of members of congress
are coming out of the woodwork saying
yeah
like obviously we should have cash in
this thing so thank you to everyone who
supported humanity forward because you
made this happen we made this happen
i've had over 50 calls with members of
congress i just had one earlier today
and they are
generally surprised to hear that three
quarters of americans are for this
um but they've been hearing tales of
suffering
from their communities and they realize
that you know we need to get cash on the
table
so uh so we're making this happen uh and
this period of time is the crucial time
because we can all see from the calendar
december doesn't have that many days
left congress needs to reauthorize
funding
for the government the deadline was
december 11th they pushed it to the 18th
so this is the window when relief will
actually either leave congress and get
signed into law
before your end or it will not and
certainly we're all
rooting for wanted to pass and two for
it to include
cash for the people it's kind of
exciting is like we can actually say
that the work we've been doing had a
pretty big hand in this like i don't
care what the press says i think they
don't ignore you or whatever they
normally do but the reality is we've
been moving this ball forward this is
the greatest thing i have ever touched
you know the greatest thing like if if
if we can unlock
let's call it 120 to 200 billion dollars
for
everyday americans i mean like like who
can do that that's you know like
you could work frankly you know
thousands of lifetimes and like never
uh never come come near that um so the
fact that
you me everyone who's listening to this
if you supported
uh humanity forward helped make this
happen this would be
the greatest thing i have been a part of
if we helped get
hundreds of billions of dollars out the
door that actually was
heading straight to people families
households
like what can top that so pumped to to
have had a hand in this but we need to
do more
and congress needs to do a whole lot
more yeah
um so the efforts we're making have been
high roi very very quickly
and it's been this is i think the actual
headline is that this is
the first bipartisan cash relief bill
ever proposed and that is exciting and
uh it's looking more promising every day
so thank you yang gang and listeners if
you have donated
donate to humanity forward it's
literally like a hundred million percent
return
for the country or you really cannot top
that seriously
and and i gotta say like talking to
these members has been very encouraging
where uh lisa blunt rochester was the
secretary of labor in
delaware so she's acutely aware she's
also the co-founder of the future of
work caucus that exists
uh so she is all over this stuff uh and
david mckinley representing west
virginia like he sees what's going on
when people are struggling i mean west
virginia has
has some some issues uh and you know
like he wants to help so
it's really and it's not just them i
mean again i've had
dozens of conversations where uh you
know it it's really interesting zach and
i'm going to talk about this
i think with you in a minute when you
talk to excellent people in congress
and there are excellent people in
congress like it really makes clear
just how messed up the system is that
you can like embed
uh dozens of excellent people in a
system that like you know is not
clicking it's not delivering value to
the american people
um so in in many ways i think we have to
try and extricate ourselves from the
people
which is very hard to do if you know if
you're a person yourself or you know a
journalist
like extricate yourself in the people
and look at the structures and the
institutions
as to why things aren't working i've
been so frustrated and i think a lot of
americans have
like are we really not doing anything
like like andrew yang has to literally
come in and swoop in to get you to think
about cash relief given
in the middle of a global pandemic where
you're forcing people to stay home is
that that's what it's taking and my
question
for you is is it
there are real you've met a lot of the
really great rational congressmen and
women around the country
um is is congress full of bad apples or
is it one bad apple spoiling the whole
bunch you know like what's the ratio of
like good ones to bad ones and
and what is the what's gumming
what's gumming up the um the
polarization there
there are two parts of it zach like i
think we've been very very helpful
because we
we're uh the people's lobbyist uh and so
you have to ask yourself
who is incentivized to lobby for a
certain thing
uh and you can trace just about anything
to some interest group somewhere but
on this one there's no identifiable
interest group
aside from all of us and so
like that's the gap weight we've filled
um
and if you're a member of congress your
office gets
peppered with meeting requests from
various lobbyists and you meet with them
and you know the nature of the lobbyists
you meet with varies depending upon what
party you're in
um and so that's where your policies
tend to veer
uh and and i'm thrilled that we can help
with this but so there there are two
major structural problems number one is
uh you need a lobbyist
[Laughter]
but the the second is that the
legislative rules have become
really really tough
in terms of actually getting a law out
the book the out the door and onto the
books
so uh there's something called the
hastert rule that got adopted a number
of years ago
which is they will only consider a bill
if the majority of the majority party
approves it so think about what that
means
if let's say you're a republican member
of congress it means you can introduce
literally zero legislation
because you're not the majority party uh
and then when the majority of the
majority party
introduces it then they don't really
expect you to vote for it because
they're like look
you know we're gonna have the votes
we're gonna try and cram this uh and
and then the review process isn't even
real anymore where like sometimes
they'll be like and here's legislation
give it like a vote yes or no and then
it's like wait i haven't read this thing
and it's long
and so so you wind up with like like a
very very polarizing dynamic
uh right and so it's these kinds of
mechanics that i think people are not
uh paying attention to properly
of the things that have changed my life
through yang speaks
i'd have to say the unagi scooter is
either
number one or tied for number one
it's this freaking tesla of electric
scooters
where you get it and you zip around um
it feels like a magic carpet my kids are
so envious because they're not big
enough to ride it yet
i don't know if this says something
about my parenting but uh now uh the
older one i do stick on
the scooter in front of me and then i
whizz around on it
but it makes you feel like you're in the
future it's environmentally friendly you
just plug it in
if you live in a city it will transport
you where you want to go
uh you know without having to to
struggle with um
public transportation it's beautiful
it's slake
everyone looks at it and it's like what
is that that's the unagi
scooter for you i can't speak highly
enough about it
uh we got a second one and then
now when someone visits me like the two
of us go around
like we're in this really uh futuristic
scooter gang
where we just like whizz around and uh
generally just
have a blast we even went out at night
because these things have these
headlights that really make you seem
like a ufo
um you know it's like uh i don't know if
you've done that zach have you done that
i've gone to night um in new york
it is awesome to ride because it's
faster than the bikes generally speaking
um or the regular the slow city bikes um
and faster than runners
uh i i love it it's not that heavy
either it's like it's like 25 pounds or
so
i think 26 pounds exact weight but it
looks good folds up it's beautiful
um you can basically have like 20 miles
of range
um and they actually this is fun because
it's actually just one award cnet gave
it best all-around electric scooter and
then it won its first place
for the best electric scooter by uh
tom's guide so it's not just us starting
to rave about this thing it's real
yes and right now for a limited time you
can get 150
off for the holidays this is the lowest
price they will have
for the next year so check them out now
you will be glad
you will be grateful this if this is a
real game changer
you can get yours today at
unagiscooters.com that's
unagi scooters.com
[Music]
so i've been reading this book uh why
we're polarized by
ezra klein and it's this exhaustive
treatment as to why
we're polarized and why we can't get
along uh and it definitely
informs what's going on in congress uh
because you at this point have these two
parties
uh warring with each other and neither
side can win so we all lose
you know like uh there was a hope that
democrats would have a
governing majority after this election
and it doesn't look like that's
happening it's one reason i'm here in
georgia
is uh there's there's hope um but you
have to win two senate races
in january um and uh the cause of
polarization are
again around these incentives and these
institutions uh but the deepest
stuff that ezra unearths in this book
that blew my mind and would blow the
minds of i think most everyone listening
to this
uh two things number one there is a weak
correlation between self-identified
conservativism and liberalism
and your actual policy views i want to
say that again because i think it's so
important
there is a weak correlation between
whether i say i'm conservative or
liberal or progressive
and what i actually think on a whole
variety of issues
if you're a math person the correlation
is 0.25
for both conservatives and liberals
which is weak
a perfect correlation would be one
no correlation would be zero so it's
closer to no no correlation than
being totally consistent and that's
going to surprise everyone listening to
this
but it makes sense when you consider one
basic fact
that may not apply to you if you're
listening to this
most people don't know jack all about
policy
where uh if you say to them like hey you
liberal conservative they'll be like
conservative
and then you actually say like hey do
you think drug prices are too high
they'll be like oh yeah
uh you know it's like do you think
government should do something about
that yes
um you know or you ask them about
something they've never thought about
like federal reserve policy uh you know
they'll just make something up or parrot
whatever
uh the last thing they heard was um and
the vast majority of americans don't
have the time to become
policy walks on everything out of the
sun um
and so it turns out that the
self-identification we
have is more
um alignment with a tribe or a group or
a political identity
than it is actual uh policy
prescriptions
and so one of the things that we do very
often and i certainly do this i'll still
do it
whatever even though ezra's now
convinced me that it probably is not the
the answer
is like you try and share information
with people like say someone doesn't
believe in climate change and then
you're like well let me get you a study
or whatever like show the the study um
and this is the other finding he had
which was mind-boggling
is that if you expose someone to
information from the other perspective
it is more likely to harden their views
than it is
to change them uh
and so this really articulates why we're
struggling so badly right now
where like you think that someone else
is getting a whole different version of
the world which they kind of are
sometimes
and then you're like what no no no no
let me expose you to this article
let me have you read the study and
they're more likely to double down
on their current belief than they are to
be convinced
uh so so there so the some of the things
that yeah i know it's it's like it's a
tough there's
there's some very tough pills to swallow
in this book so more facts means more
polarization
is that i mean that's a zack's dumb way
of
paraphrasing that um no it's it's that
uh it's not an information gap the way
that people believe
um it's more um that people have
established political identities
and then they decide how they're gonna
react to a proposition based on that
identity not on
the information that they have doesn't
matter what you tell them i'm a red sox
fan
that's true i'm a buffalo bills fan
doesn't matter what you tell me how
great tom brady is
still sucks um and i know he's great but
still sucks
uh that kind of like fandom situation
it's exactly like that you have
deflategate or whatnot and if you talk
to a patriots fan they're like whatever
who cares
uh and so that this is one reason why
uh trump commands such loyalty and then
people are like
questioning like how the heck can you
support this guy because he did
x or he did why and it's like tom brady
like if that's your team then you're
like whatever who cares you know he can
do what he wants
um uh and you'll defend him
and if someone attacks them then you
actually in some cases
uh get more defensive like
it doesn't open you up it like closes
you in various ways
so that that's the reality
according to really well documented
studies like
it's very compelling stuff um that
that politics has descended into teams
um and
i think zach for you like you might
understand this more
naturally than others because you're a
big sports fan i'm a big sports fan too
so like i get it um
and and so the the blind spot a lot of
folks have is that
again they think it's an information gap
they think it's like oh if i can just
get you this piece of information then
like the light bulb will turn on
um and evidence indicates that that is
not likely to work you know one place
you can see the polarization as clear as
dayzak is here in georgia because you
cannot turn on the tv without seeing an
ad from one party or the other
and i'm not going to give you um my
rendition
of a david perdue ad okay
radical socialist john ossoff wants to
team up with radical
liberals aoc and nancy pelosi
to destroy america
vote for david perdue a vote for david
perdue is a vote to save america
vote for david perdue to save america i
approve this
music david perdue to save america
like if you think that i'm exaggerating
like pull up one of these ads on the
internet like
you're not exaggerating no it's yeah no
like like that literally
um uh like the words radical liberal and
radical socialist
every freaking five seconds i mean i
don't know if you saw the kelly left
dark red like they're the actual
lucifer incarnate um that is i almost
joked with jon ossoff when i saw him i
was like hey john um
why do we have to defeat you to save
america like what is your plot to
destroy
america you know i mean like that but
that that is literally like the level
of uh vitriol and
fear frankly uh that the republican
party is leaning into to the tune of
tens of millions of dollars here in
georgia
and it works frankly i mean like you
they're not
dumb like they're gonna bust out these
ads um
these ads worked all over the country
you know they're pretty sure they're
gonna work here in georgia so they're
leaning into them you don't really need
to make an affirmative case for yourself
um you can just try to try and scare the
out of people about the other
person that's another thing that popped
up in ezra klein's book
um when it looked at motivators
political motivators
uh animosity toward the other team is
actually a bigger political motivator
than
excitement about your team and that's
true on both sides wow
it's another reason why you're always
seeing these inflammatory
accusations and ads that are trashing
the other side
because that actually drives voting
behavior it drives donations
it drives energy much much more so than
uh talking about all the good you're
going to do uh and
i mean and that that's like an
interesting phenomenon given that zach
you you and i know it's like
we ran a campaign where we didn't really
trash anyone you know we're just like
like we're we're just going to be
positive and do our thing
um and it turns out that the numbers say
that
uh trashing people worse that's a bad
strategy
hence the ads that that you know i'm
seeing here in georgia every day
so uh so just wanted to share the
underground experience here in georgia
the the joys of political advertising
oh my gosh um this
i mean i'm so i've so many thoughts on
this one i imagine social media fuels
this so i think we're heading that
direction but it gets
exacerbated by our media oh yeah social
that sort of thing
a lot of people potentially listening to
this actually think and a lot of people
support you
andrew actually think you are one of the
closest ways to solve for this
because you're one of the it takes a lot
of people to run for office and a lot of
people be successful at it and you are
one of the few at the
let's call it the top tier of
politicians in the country
that quote unquote politicians um
that yeah i don't like that but
you're not on a team you know um and
it's funny because like even
you are like trying to get the democrats
to win uh but there are things
you know we have been very very i'm
doing it because i think it's the right
thing for the people you know what i
mean
like uh like whoever whoever wants to um
try and get our government working and
get cash out of the door like i'm gonna
be for
um yeah that so so that one of the big
problems
if you believe what ezra is arguing
which i generally do
um that politics has become teams and
tribal
uh and then you believe also that we're
only allowed to have
two teams uh then you're in trouble
you know because um
because that is like well pick one of
these two sides and uh let's make them
of like
um you know relatively wow
even proportion the sports analogies if
like if you had to pick between
it's like the giants and the jets they
both suck i know the giants are
technically going to be a
possible playoff team first place new
york giants uh we like you know football
i mean that's a bad example because i do
like new york but you like you know
you've got
it's two bad teams if you will and
they're both equally bad in their own
way and you try to
self-justify to yourself what's better
or worse and
um so i i would say i i would say
objectively
like i believe the democratic party is a
better
um party than the republican party right
now
um and i'm starting to policy listening
to this uh yeah
in terms of policy in terms of
functionality in terms of like actually
trying to
like listen to um experts and you know
like like folks like that like the
republican party
has had some historic strengths and
there are a lot of values of it that
i appreciate and a lot of other people
appreciate and have many friends who are
historic republicans
but you have to say that trump took over
that party and and then
has turned it into something that um is
different than it was
not that long ago and the clear the
clearest sign of that is that the
republican party platform at the rnc uh
this past cycle
was a it was like a blank piece of paper
whatever
trump says is our platform and we don't
want to actually write anything down
because then we're going to be exposed
to hypocrisy after trump says something
different tomorrow
so so that so that's like uh you know i
mean that that's not
the republican party of yesteryear
that's for sure um so one of the the
dangers here zach is like
um you know uh you don't want to kind of
um uh both sides this thing in like a
particular way
um because the parties are going through
different things right now
and i certainly have my problems with
the democratic party for sure
um but but they are they're they're
they're like a different set of problems
for
each party it
is tough trying to stay healthy during
this pandemic
and one thing that helps me stay healthy
and a lot of other people stay healthy
right now
is freshly what the heck is freshly they
send you a fresh
cooked meal it's delicious it's healthy
you don't have to do a whole heck of a
lot at all
it's like you know when you're in those
grocery stores and you see that
like rotisserie chicken meal in the in
the container and you're like ooh
and you know you just like get that
thing and you bring it home and eat it
up and
it's good it's like that it's
essentially those meals that get sent to
you
uh i know you're like wow that sounds
pretty fantastic and you're not the only
one who thinks so
because one and a half million satisfied
freshly users do the exact same thing
they skip the shopping prepping cooking
and cleaning they just focus on the
eating and the healthy living
so for a limited time freshly is
offering our listeners forty dollars off
their first two orders at freshly.com
yang that's freshly.com yang feed your
body right
just get some freaking freshly in there
tons of people are using this
join in skip the shopping prep and
cooking cleanup freshly.com
yang i love this thing i'm ordering here
in jacksonville too it's great
[Applause]
regardless of how you feel about either
party though i think you'd have to say
that
if you are this polarized and having two
teams is very problematic because then
you just split power
nothing gets done your legislative
incentives are
uh more tied to blaming the other side
than
um improving people's lives i mean that
that so that that's why we're all so
uh disheartened and you have these
structural forces that are that are
making it
so so then the obvious question is like
how do you change this
um and i i think this is going to be
something i talked to
our guest today ryan knight about
but to me the the answer is mechanical
which i know is going to be like
mechanical
but if you listen to this and say look
you know it's not about necessarily
um uh trying to get
people a particular piece of info uh and
yang gang
like we should keep doing what we're
doing like it does work
on on a lot of folks who just haven't
seen our ideas
and like i do it every day so i don't
want to discourage us from like you know
actually reaching people who can be
convinced um but
to me the answer has to be ranked choice
voting or something that actually
enables you to
to have a different less bilateral us or
them dynamic
um and and also enables you to put to
bed this entire
you're going to waste your vote thing
that so many people get whenever they
are thinking about voting third party um
then you know you're immediately an
idiot if you vote for anything that's
not one of the two major parties
um and that's a mechanical problem if
you have ranked choice voting then
you're perfectly smart to vote
to vote for whoever you want uh and
so that to me is the great change that
can actually
shift the dynamic and
break up the us versus them polarization
in the presidential primary we were the
most liked candidate
but um finished around seventh or so in
total votes
if ranked choice voting existed i we can
all honestly say i think
andrew would have finished top five
possibly top three um
in a polarized environment so that's
like the kind of
because people a lot of people didn't
want to vote for andrew um because he
wasn't a front-runner like
well i don't wanna i don't want so and i
don't want bernie to win i don't want
whoever
um so i don't waste my vote right yeah
that and
so the the current system does reward
folks who continuously make electability
like they're their main thing which ends
up rewarding folks who have more
resources which tends to reward
um folks who are closer to the money pot
so so
there are like a lot of advantages um
to making this change and there are 26
states
that have ballot initiatives
that would enable you to get ranked
choice voting uh for your state's
elections
um so you can see what whether
uh that's your state so you're writing a
book which is um
i think you've been public about a
couple times in the pod about what we're
writing about trying to dive into this
which i love because you're doing
research and then you come up with these
crazy ideas on the pod or good ideas in
the pod
um have you looked into other countries
um that don't let's say they have other
rank choice voting but i know in in
various european countries they have
other parties
um and how that's played out because
they still have the fandom piece but
they have more options
yeah it's actually unusual to only have
two major parties
uh if you look around the world most
parliaments have multiple parties and
then you have different parties having
to get together
uh to get a law passed um so we're
unusual
in that in in our degree of polarization
and there are a lot of ways in which the
duopoly has been
fixed in place um where these party
mechanics and the parties control
just about everything um and there was a
quote from boss tweed
uh who used to run new york that i liked
it said you can do the electing if i can
do the nominating
uh and that's really like the system we
have right now
where you know like like the party
controls the primary
you have like a subset of folks who can
um
influence that and then by the time it
gets to the general like people looking
up being like one of my choices like
what's going on
so if you have open primaries ranked
choice voting
uh final five candidates um make it to
the general
uh and then you have like a real
diversity of perspectives you could have
uh like a genuine third party emerge
uh like that that to me is the answer um
and you know i'm excited about trying to
share
what got me here um uh in the days ahead
um but yeah it's been fun working on
this act because like i always want to
learn uh it's one reason i love the
podcast is that we bring out people i
can learn from
um and uh try and get some ideas out
there that will actually
help solve the real problems and i'm now
convinced
i used to think that the problem was
that not enough people knew about
universal basic income
uh which is still a problem but now the
majority of them
but now and automation yeah but that but
now the majority of americans are for
universal basic income
um but we still can't get cash relief as
part of the
you know like pandemic belief and so i'm
like okay what the hell is going on now
and then you get there and be like oh
it's because congress is dysfunctional
for various reasons and our political
system is dysfunctional for various
reasons
and so now so now my attention's turned
towards that
and it's fun too because like we're
going into the you know we're advancing
i mean we're making progress
and then you learn like could i have
known this stuff before
um all of the experiences of this last
number of
of months and years like heck no um so
but now i know um and so hopefully now
that we know
more we can do something about it it's i
think one of my takeaways from
running andrew was that the parties
so it's like uh one of my things i've
been receiving and talking about a bit
is
that the traditional gatekeepers are
dying um
but they're not dead so these parties
our political parties are
weak in a lot of ways but they're not
they're not gone yet if you will and
that we did a lot like and we are proof
that they are weak and that we came out
of nowhere
um wielded the internet and the people
but we're also proof that they're still
strong yes but we're also proof that
they're
that we weren't good we weren't strong
enough right um trump
played um more aggressive populism
um than we than you are you're more like
a rational populist but he wasn't
he was above them these are just two
different landscapes
like the republican landscape is much
less
uh institution-bound whereas the
democratic landscape is
very tied up within terms of the media
you're for trump and it's like any you
talk to any republican friend if you
have them
and even myself self my own family like
traditionally like republican
it is an asset to not be of the
government that is a plus that is a
check in the plus column or like i'm not
a politician i'm an outsider trying to
fix things like great you know how to
run a real organization awesome
democrats every time we polled like i'm
an outsider
i'm not a traditional politician it did
not poll that well if you look at trust
and media generally
it's uh 40 general population
20 republicans 60 something percent
democrats
so so democrats yeah so democrats like
trust the media trust institutions and
then if you show up and you're like hey
we should do something different they're
like
should we it's really interesting it's
like democrats in some ways they are
kind of like change resistant um
because they're more institutional you
know what i mean
and uh and and republicans um
don't believe the media as much and so
they don't care what the media is saying
and whatnot and you know so like so
trump could just override the whole
thing um but in the in a democratic
primary
it's a lot tougher and you and i ran
that gauntlet you know like
i mean i remember vividly i'd show up to
things and these reporters
um would want nothing to do with us and
then if they did talk to us they would
do it in a way that was like
get a load of this guy you know like and
and it was and like it changed
um month to month so by the end
it was better um but
still the biggest outpouring of press we
got
uh was when i dropped out
[Laughter]
it was like weren't a threat anymore
yeah there was like this giant like
buildup and then it's like
and yeah that guy was actually talking
sense and then i'm like
so there are different media landscapes
uh there's
a much different level of institutional
trust and one of my real fears for the
democratic party
is that they will be the last people
saying it's okay
calm down these institutions are working
and then the rest of
america will be like you
like that's like that is the great fear
uh and you know
and so my recipe at the time was
okay get a hold of government then do
big things and like try and demonstrate
that it can work
uh and then the fact that that does not
seem like it's likely given you know the
current division of government the lack
of
like a wave and the rest of it like now
i've got this like
foreboding oh no uh because the the
mistrust is just going to keep rising
um and you know like our institutions
are
frankly like you know going to perform
worse not better
uh generally i mean do i think
democratic leadership will upgrade some
of the
um government response to coven and some
other things heck yes it will
like you know like like they're not
going to be as incoherent and
unconcerned
uh as the trump administration you know
like that's real but that's you know
it's
one reason why i'm very very glad that
it's happening um
but if you look at like the general
landscape it's like our institutions
getting
better smarter more effective more
efficient it's like it's tough to say
you know like to the extent that uh that
there are things that are going for in
leaps and bounds
unfortunately uh it it it's primarily
technology various commercial
enterprises
like the these uh startups that now like
you know if you need anything delivered
to your door it'll just freaking
magically show up because
like they got hundreds of millions of
dollars to invest and i'll let you know
now
i mean doordash just had an ipo like i
was looking at their evaluation and
they did well did millions yeah it
popped because of common sense you're
all looking around and being like huh
in the future or the present do we need
door dash and everyone's like heck yes
well here's a fun one for you here's a
fun one
right on right on point what you're
saying is that
in washington dc now get it it's a city
um
but that in this race 92
of washington dc people who live there
voted for biden so it was literally nine
and only it's five percent there are
five percent of
voters in that in washington dc that are
republican
and to me like that like obviously the
cities it's usually on the high end like
70 70 30 kind of 80 20 in that range
but for that high in that population to
me is like just a perfect example of
like oh no the people that like run the
institutions and still believe in them
are all gonna go
democrat if you will you put any
democrat on there and you have a very
similar thing a lot more you know
there's some anti-trump there too but
um and that is the problem with
democrats where we believe in failed
systems over and over and over
it's one reason why a lot of republicans
liked me is because they sensed that
i'm a human being i'm an individual uh
and
like i'm not of the institution and
they're like ooh like i kind of
like you i kind of like this guy's vibe
and
uh you know and i appreciate that
uh you know like i i'm i'm working on
something um
around the mistrust
um and and a lot of it is well-founded
frankly and and there's this like
incredible um
failure to acknowledge it on the part of
a lot of
our institutions themselves and like the
media organs and whatnot
where um you know when there's
institutional failure there's just like
nothing to see here like you know keep
it moving
like it could be like the media
organization itself having a problem
it's like nothing to see here
you know it's been hard and it's been
different for us this time around but to
help to still see
why so many people voted for donald
trump
given the environment we are in you know
what i'm saying given that there's a
pandemic
you could argue something like nine
million more people 10 million more
people voted for trump
like you know a lot when i checked the
end of the election it was like 68
million now it's like 74 million as the
votes continue to come in
and that should be the problem for
democrats it's like we think we're good
we think we're right and i think we are
like from a moral standpoint or even
like ideas standpoint but as a
party we are doing things and saying
things
and being hypocritical how many freaking
democratic mayors or governors are
saying you know locked down but then
they're going to private dinners
themselves like that stuff like that
is where republicans get so so angry
it's like i'd rather throw the donald
trump in there
and blow it up than you know stand for
that kind of
um bad ideas if you will yeah it's
the fact that we have these two parties
and
um not you know not that much else to
choose from uh so i'm excited to talk to
ryan knight um you know his social media
handle says it all a proud socialist
about uh what he sees because like you
know he
criticizes the democratic party um
[Music]
uh as being out of touch very
consistently and regularly so excited to
sit down with him
um and find out his views on what we can
do better
i'm i'm so curious about this
conversation because
and i hope we get to you know on top of
this that socialism
it's the way it's defined where
government seizing means of production
has not worked there's no example of it
anywhere that it has worked but there
are elements
of socialism that have worked great
whether it's healthcare or education
or i mean canada is a decent example and
most of the norwegian countries are
solid examples so i think
democrats aren't the best at messaging
we kind of tend to throw the baby out
with the bath water
or vice versa when we when we talk about
some big ideas but so this i'm excited
to hear you
talk to a socialist because you're not a
socialist
but some of your policies are aligned
with the visions
of socialism in many ways so i think
that's really exciting so ryan knight
joining yang speaks let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yang speaks we're all about
fighting for your data for our data
we have a data dividend project trying
to make it so that
the interests of the people get
represented at in state houses
around the country we won prop 24 which
is
making data rights a real thing in
california thank you to everyone who
supported
prop 24 but in the meantime if you're
not in california
and you want to have your data be
anonymous truly anonymous
we recommend that you use expressvpn
vpn's a virtual private network an
expressvpn
is rated number one by cnet and wired
all these big companies use it
it's like a portal to the internet
anonymously
through some server someplace else you
can do whatever you want you can get
content from other countries
uh wee wee major whatever and i'm
kidding i don't know why i thought of
france just then so stop handing over
your personal data to the big tech
companies
that frankly do monitor your activities
sometimes they even sell it
protect yourself with a vpn that we
trust here at yangsfeet
to stay safe online visit expressvpn.com
yang
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com yang to get
three extra months
for free go to expressvpn.com yang to
learn more
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
activist the host of the amped up
podcast and advisor
to the movement for a people's party
proud socialist himself ryan knight
welcome ryan
thank you so much andrew i am looking
forward to this conversation and thank
you for all the work you're doing
uh to make sure that families uh get the
cash relief that they desperately need
right now
during this pandemic oh yeah we're
pushing congress every day i had several
calls just today
it's been fun prodding legislators and
certainly
i am thrilled that they will spend time
with me uh you know that i
have like a stature where my call with
andrew yang on their calendar is not
like oh no what did my staff do
they turn around and like berate someone
um
so so that's that's front and center
i want to give people a sense of your
progression
because you've been through a lot as an
activist you've done a lot of different
things
but i love your origin story on a
personal level where you bounce back
between
seattle and alaska like your dad is a
commercial fisherman
so you went from red to blue to red to
blue to red to blue on the regular when
you were growing up is that right
yeah so i uh my family divorced when i
was very young when i was two
and uh my father moved to alaska to
become a commercial fisherman
in a little town called petersburg
alaska and my mom
stayed in seattle uh and so i kind of
had you know i had this childhood where
i went from
you know the city life from a you know
big liberal city like seattle
where i went to school uh to in the
summers and during christmas time i
would go up to a little
to alaska which is you know to a little
small fishing village called petersburg
which is you know a cut the country life
and and you know
definitely a red state and definitely
you know a town of trump supporters and
so
you know in my childhood i kind of got
to see both views uh i i got
to see you know what it was like for
more rural communities and and what it's
like living in in a big city which i
think gives you
gave me kind of a unique perspective on
politics that
you know it doesn't matter you know if
you're from that small
you know rural town or if you're in the
big city i think that you know
every day working class people are you
know they just want to have
the same opportunities as everyone else
and it feels like especially now in this
climate
you know over the last decade that it's
become harder and harder in america
for the working class you know while the
rich just keep getting richer and richer
that's great exposure for you if you
were a netflix movie character you
definitely would have
fallen in love during one of the alaska
summers it would have been one of those
situations you know
i've had some some many great alaska
summers just with those beautiful
sunsets and
it's it stays light in alaska for like
18 hours you know
um during the summer so we would play
baseball like on the mud flats and
you know it was definitely an
interesting it was it was interesting
and then of course you know i i
am gay and so that was all entering that
into the equation was also very
interesting because
you go up there it was like a whole new
curve ball for my my fish my father
who's a lifelong conservative and
um you know and that was a added a whole
new perspective to it but
uh you know today my fam my father and i
are have a great relationship and it
wasn't always that way so i'm so
grateful for that and i'm so grateful
that we both
see each other and respect each other
and and learn from each other you know i
learned so much from my dad
uh just as he has learned a lot from me
and you know there was a period of about
a decade where we didn't speak and so
oh wow well i'm so glad you guys have a
great relationship now
uh so you then went to college in
california and then you worked in
corporate finance
uh for a number of years and that was um
also on the west coast is that right
yeah so i went to santa clara university
in the bay area
uh and i graduated and i worked in the
silicon valley at a startup company
uh that did business valuations of other
startups other smaller companies and
it was right after the dot-com yeah it
was right after the dot-com boom so
there was just a lot of you know
activity happening and it you know it
was uh
it was a it was a hard economy coming
out of school but you know after like
six years of corporate finance it was
it was suffocating you know it wasn't
for me and and uh you know i
i've realized after that that i needed
to do something where i was making a
difference and so i got involved in
politics
on a local level and i worked for the
mayor of west hollywood for a long time
john duran and i helped him get elected
uh
and then i also worked for another
prominent politician
uh in kind of the los angeles area
uh and then after trump happened i
realized you know that i needed to kind
of get involved in a bigger way
and uh i helped a grassroots pack
in 2018 uh called build the wave that
did you know flipped about 40 seats
in the house from from red to blue and
then after that i kind of realized that
like you know
establishment politics you know while
they have a lot of good intentions um
that we needed more than kind of what
the establishment was offering
you know that just you know going on
television and sedating the public with
these
lofty platitudes of hope and change
isn't enough if you're not going to back
it up with
actual policies that are going to
improve people's lives and move this
country forward
you know policies like medicare for all
and a green new deal and universal basic
income
that you have been a huge advocate for
you know it's it's
i kind of started to realize that like
you know
a man much wiser than me one by the name
of albert einstein once said that we
can't solve our problems
with the same level of of consciousness
or thought
that created the problems you know and
for and for
a half century now in washington dc you
know both corporate parties
have been governing for wall street and
uh giant corporations and the ruling
class
and they haven't been governing for the
people there there's there is a real
shift and you can see into the numbers
where the economy starts diverging
around the 70s as you say so it's been
about 50 years
certainly a lot of it sped up during the
reagan
era but you see this very steep
divergence between
returns on capital returns on labor uh
between
increases in ever in compensation
and various costs where like our
standard of living
should be much higher but uh you know i
mean i can't believe how comp hasn't
moved
in real terms since then even though
we've gotten much much wealthier
and i think that a lot of folks
essentially pretend like it's still the
70s you know like our economic
understanding is uh cast in this
nonsense
like frozen portrait of like a 70s
economy where
hey if i get this money and i'm a
company then i'll turn around and like
hire lots of workers and i'll treat them
well and i'll give them benefits
and i'll care about what goes on in my
backyard and companies just stopped
doing that
decades ago uh and we just pretend that
they still operate that way
yeah you know and i would say like look
maybe like right after trump got elected
i thought that you know i kind of
initially thought well gosh you know
like
he's the problem but as i did more
research and kind of started to unpack
our political system i quickly realized
that you know america isn't failing
because of one corrupt president
america is failing because our entire
system is corrupt
you know for the last 40 years we've had
failed trickle-down economics for the
working class
and we've had you know massive bailouts
subsidies tax breaks and and corporate
socialism
you know for wall street and the ruling
class and it's created this society that
we live in like look in some yeah we are
the richest
nation in the history of the world but
we don't even have universal health care
you know we're the richest nation in the
history of the world but we don't have
universal
child care or you know universal public
college or universal basic income
and so we have all this wealth that has
just been concentrated
more and more into the hands of the one
percent heck man we don't even have
clean water for a lot of people you know
there's like a lot of basic stuff
we don't even have clean water in some
communities and so it's it's about
it's about equity it's about fairness
it's about having a government that is
on our side
right like and and also i think what's
what's what's been very noticeable in
this moment is like
and i think it you can look back in 2008
after the financial crisis
right what did our government do after
the financial crisis
they didn't bail four trillion dollars
to bail out of wall street yeah the four
trillion dollars like just
a lot of small businesses and our
mom-and-pop shops they
bailed out wall street and giant
corporations the very people who caused
the crisis
you know the crucial decision at that
point ryan was you could have bailed out
homeowners if you wanted to you could
have made a lot of the mortgage debt
that was forcing people out of their
homes yeah and we saw 10 million
americans lose their homes but i think
the same way our government
you know just after the financial crisis
they went and they they did what they do
best you know bailed out their corporate
donors
we saw the same thing happen during this
pandemic right
with the you know and they called it the
cares act well it had a lot of care for
the billionaire class
but it didn't have enough care for for
small businesses and
and the working class and since the
cares act was passed you know in
february and march
we've seen you know u.s billionaires
increase their wealth by
a trillion dollars uh you know while
working people can barely keep their
heads above water people
got that 1200 in the cares act and so
you think okay
like that then that money must have been
for us right uh but if you do the math
if you have a 2.2 trillion dollar act
which you do
uh and you send 1200 out to let's be
aggressive and say
a couple hundred million people you're
looking at about 10
of that act was money for the people
uh so don't get it messed up people
where it's like oh you know 2.2 trillion
came to us no no no
yeah like the vast majority of that went
to big corporates
yeah and look at the and the
consequences have been startling i mean
here we are the richest nation on earth
and feeding america which is one of the
biggest you know food banks in our
country
has now reported that we're going to see
50 million people face
food you know food insecurity this year
and we have 40 million americans who are
uh are facing eviction with the
moratorium set to expire at the end of
this month and so
you know it just it doesn't have to be
this way you know
this many people it doesn't be
struggling and i think that you could
choose to do better immediately
we can't we can demand better you know
and i look at someone like the
democratic party look like
i've been a democrat for 18 years i'm a
lifelong democrat
but finally like this last you know year
and a half my eyes kind of opened up and
i saw that like
look i've never voted for a republican
in my life i don't support the
republican party
but you know the republican party isn't
also they're a little more transparent
they're not saying
that you know climate change is real and
they're not saying that healthcare is a
human right
you know they're not kind of making
these promises and spouting these
platitudes
where's some rough stuff ryan right but
you've got these democrats
you know like joe biden or nancy pelosi
who will go on
cnn and they'll say climate change is
real but then they won't support the
policy like a green new deal to do
something about it
[Music]
so pumped that we have a new sponsor
here i want to talk to you guys about
hawthorne which we found and it is i've
never been excited to take a shower and
use a body wash before that's kind of
what i feel so here's
what happens so a lot of our ads we do
like these tailored uh
we love quizzes apparently so you take
this quiz online and it's random
from like what type
hey what what is your priorities when it
comes to deodorant do you want
antiperspirant do you
sweat a lot do you just want it for
smell that sort of thing what are your
priorities for a body wash do you want
to smell good you want to
scrub dirt like whatever your
preferences are and that goes from
lotion to
hand soap to face soap to all these
different
uh conditioner all these things your
hair your body your skin and all these
things
and then they send you a custom version
of um
all of these whatever one you pick and
honestly i love it i have
been trying all of their products even
i'm like a stickler on
a certain types of deodorant i don't
even like their deodorant um so if you
want to
upgrade your self-care routine
hellothern is like this fun convenient
way to get extremely high quality
products tailored
just for you just very cool it is fun
how now there are
more and more tailored personal products
for guys
you know i grew up in a time when it was
just like one thing
speed stick yeah irish spring
bar soap oh yeah that was the good stuff
man
like clean as a whistle um but now
you have like legit self-care that's
tailored to you
because not every guy is alike you know
we actually have different
um skin different hair different
grooming needs and the rest of it
pretty much anything is access to do in
this area you should definitely do have
you seen zach
he's a very very well-groomed gentleman
um
you know uh competing around him
[Laughter]
right about the trail he was always
shaming us with his
hair and his face all right his facial
hair
just kidding i do i really do like
hawthorne go to hawthorne.com and use
promo code yang to get 10
off your first purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot co promo code yang hawthorne.co
promo code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
we left it off where trump gets elected
and you turn your attention
to like okay and then you help with the
pack in 2018
um and then at some point you had kind
of like this political awakening you're
describing so i wanted you to walk folks
through
what you were doing 2018 where you were
in 2020 and then when
what pushed you to a point where now
you're like okay i'm not even
a democrat anymore i'm gonna go um full
socialist
i think for me is you know in 2018 it
was like vote blue no matter who you
know just
blue wave let's just flip the house and
everything will be better now
you're doing the work yeah and we did
the work and and we flipped the house
and
my big epiphany again it was that
democrats make these promises you know
they sedate us with these great
platitudes
that yes yeah climate change is real but
that's not enough you know when we have
a climate crisis bearing down on our
communities
it's not enough to just identify the
problem you have to support
legislation and a policy to actually do
something about the problem
2020 you started out in the warren camp
is that right i
initially backed warren for about you
know maybe
i think it was five months uh in 2019
and then
right after iowa when it was very clear
that warren did not have a path to the
white house
and it was also very clear that this
moment in history
you came in for yang no i'm kidding i'm
kidding
i'll tell you you came on my radar
shortly thereafter i mean you've
definitely been on my radar
but uh and i also think we need to talk
about the corporate media component
because i think the reason you weren't
on as many people's radars is because of
just the way our corporate media
covers our politics and there's been
some very interesting reporting
that you know candidates that were
fighting back against the status quo
and actually fighting for policies that
challenged the status quo
candidates like yourself and tulsi
gabbard and even bernie you know ever
since 2016
that they they don't really cover those
candidates and they tend to i
right ryan i noticed that i wasn't quite
getting the same coverage as some other
folks
they tend to they tend to favor the
candidates who just kind of want to keep
everything
business as usual and won't disrupt the
status quo
and that would maybe be fine if the
status quo was working for the majority
of americans
but we live in a moment in history where
it's not you're hitting it your critique
hits out something very fundamental
which is like the democratic party do
unfortunately take on this role of the
status quo party
sort of it's like look it's like they're
like the business as usual party
uh and business don't say that because
if you
if you criticize them or not even like
after 2018 i wasn't as vocal as i am now
i would just basically
say look vote blue no matter who isn't
enough
because it's like how how is a party
ever going to get better
if you're just going to hand them your
vote and tell them that they don't have
to do anything to get that vote
what incentive do you give them if you
just say well we're going to vote for
you no matter what you do
right because you're not giving them
actually an incentive to work for the
people you're not
demanding something in return for your
vote and this is where you've landed now
i know because now you think the problem
is the duopoly
because one of the things the democratic
party can do very powerfully is like
you got to vote for me because are you
really going to help that guy win
you know and so then if you're like a
sane progressive you're like oh
snap like i really don't want that guy
to win so they got they got a point
there
no abs you're absolutely right and i
think also like as long as progressives
have nowhere to go
as long as there's not a major viable
third party option
to challenge the duopoly which we don't
have now we have smaller parties that
have been trying you know the green
party
has tried for the past three three to
four decades to break through the
duopoly
uh and they haven't seen much success
and again there's
it's because you know look these two
corporate parties have been building
this power for a long
time now you know this this didn't all
just start with donald trump when he
when he became president
and it's not going to end now that he's
no longer president again you know these
parties have been
governing this way and putting their
corporate donors
over the basic needs of the people for a
very very very long time and i think
that
look i think that each party does it you
know they're both guilty of it i think
and i think that you know you if you for
instance if you turn on cnn
you know or msnbc most of the pundits on
there will basically say that you know
the republicans they're the problem and
trump is the problem and then if
you turn on fox news you know it'll
the pundits will basically tell you that
no it's those democrats of the problem
and it's nancy pelosi's the problem and
so
if you can divide the 99 and you can
keep
you know the red team versus the blue
team you know the 99
so busy fighting we're so busy fighting
each other that we don't notice that
these
corrupt politicians in washington are
busy rigging the system against us
and rigging the system for the one
percent you know and that's really to me
kind of the crux of the issue that
there's so much you know
the american people are so blinded by
political partisanship that they don't
see that neither of these corporate
parties in essence
truly works for the people look at this
year like the proof is in the pudding
wall street in 2020 gave more money to
joe biden and the democrats
than they did to donald trump and the
republicans i'm not surprised isn't that
you know i think joe's going to be
like a better steward of the economy um
and people on uh you know like on the
boards of these companies we're getting
tired of the unpredictability of trump i
think
but to your fundamental critique that uh
the duopoly is the problem and
partisanship is distracting us from
solving the real problems
uh let's say i agree which i do um so
and i love the way your mind works like
you've gone through a progression
that i've gone through a version of in
my own way i think there are different
people who've gone through a version of
it
but i i do want to just beat this step a
little bit more
for the folks who right now are
still vote blue no matter who the way
you were a number of
years ago not that long ago it sounds
like two years ago
yeah like two years literally no two
years ago i was literally
helping more establishment democrats get
elected
so i just want to trace those steps
because i think it's really important so
you're helping establishment democrats
get elected
you support bernie in 16 as i did i
when i heard bernie for the first time
kind of really identify
the campaign finance issues and that you
know both parties were
taking money from giant corporations in
wall street and you know governing for
the ruling class and
not governing for the working class i
had the same experience right where like
i listened to a bernie speech
in 15 or 16 and i was like i agree with
every word that man just said
but i also think is what's important in
my evolution is like
although i voted for bernie in 2016
right after
i i was a good little democrat you know
and i got right on the hillary
i jumped right on the head for hillary
for sure and i voted for hillary
but i think that one of the messages
that the corporate media
again that has such an influence on our
politics it was kind of
their message was well bernie is
addressing these kind of core
fundamental issues
with our government and in our economy
where you know the rich again keep
getting richer and richer
and the poor keep getting poor and
poorer and just the unsustainable nature
of an economy that continues to prop up
the ruling class and and at the extent
and take and take advantage of and take
for granted the working class and
and that this the working class has has
been carrying this nation
on its back for the last 50 years uh and
not seeing you know
uh increase especially the first number
of months with covid i mean the working
class has really been carrying us all
around yeah so so the message i took
after he lost it was like the court was
like great job bernie but like
that was unrealistic you know it was
like you know everyone in this country
having health care just
unrealistic and you know it was like but
but go for you bernie and they kind of
gave him a pat on the back and then it
was like
i kind of went back to sleep after that
i was a little upset and then i was like
well
you know i'll just you know i've been a
democrat for so long and i supported
hillary and
so i kind of just got back and and then
after hillary lost i
i think this is important after hillary
lost the dnc
and hillary's campaign they did a good
pr job of kind of blaming
everyone else but themselves for the
reason that they lost you know they
blamed russia they blamed
you know they blamed the burn they
blamed the bernie bros they blamed
jill stein they only blamed the green
party they blamed everyone else
but actually the fact that this kind of
mild toast neo-liberal politics that the
the democratic establishment uh
campaigns on and governs with
it it's kind of been leaving out the
working class the most damning thing i
thought they said
after the fact was uh and you know i
imagine she would
would not want to repeat this maybe she
would or the democrats might be
repeating this even now i don't know
but she said well i won the areas that
uh that accounted for the vast majority
of the economy and economic growth
um and i was like what the hell is the
point of that
where it's like where it's like like the
places where your
economy's not growing as much don't
matter as
much because the people there what like
like that that could
like that statement um i thought was one
of the worst
uh like kind of post mortem
comments about why they lost because
um it you know it sort of suggested that
like well
like these people are not like you know
people that
um we should be valuing their votes the
same way well absolutely and i think
that
you know part of the reason i and i've
been so inspired in the progressive
movement is that
you know the progressive movement is is
about policies that deliver
dignity and justice for everyone you
know progressive policies don't leave
anyone
out or any economies behind or in any
state
so so this is so this is 2017 the
postmortem turns you off in a particular
way
actually no i i initially i fell for
their post-mortem that's what i'm saying
like initially i was like
i got kind of sucked into like yeah you
know i
even though i voted for bernie in 20 in
the primary i kind of got sucked into
the
establishment narrative for the first
six months and and
look the the liberal media is very
powerful and the democratic
establishment is really good at kind of
crafting these narratives and also
kind of pandering and you know look i'm
a member of the lgbtq community they do
a great job of pandering to our
community
but do they are they truly representing
our community when they're not
supporting
universal health care you know and
they're not actually supporting policies
that help you know lgbtq people at the
margins
and so again i was still kind of falling
for the platitudes for
you know i was a big obama guy you know
the hope and change
but my so my real epiphany didn't happen
until after we flipped the house
and we made the house blue and then it
was like trump was clearly committing a
few impeachable offenses
and pelosi it was like we had to beg her
to impeach him
it was like we had to beg her for about
six months
just for her to do her job you know
after the mueller report really was
released and it was clear
that he obstructed justice pelosi didn't
want to take any action
it wasn't until after that summer when
the ukraine thing happened and after
months and months of pressure from
activist groups and i was one of the
people that was
pressuring pelosi hard back then that
she finally did it
and she kind of impeached him on his
more lesser offenses so
what i kind of saw after the democrats
took the house too and
and the other part is even though i was
working for this pack that was
there were some progressives that we
supported in the pack but it wasn't
necessarily
the candidates that i would pick now you
know the candidates that i would
that you know now it's like if you don't
support medicare for all
and agree new deal and ubi like i'm
probably not going to support your
campaign so you you become more
uh um extreme i suppose and i don't mean
that as a bad thing at all because the
thing is yeah you could say a little bit
more
progressive or radical you know but
radical
radical compassion so you know like i am
uh in agreement on like the the policy
prescriptions you're you're
describing you know with like some um
caveats
i would say too on my side um i you know
i was
pro-impeachment when it was happening
but i i thought i was like this is going
to be such a fiasco because this is
going to consume all their energies
they're not going to get it he's going
to claim exoneration like
like the whole thing i mean should they
do it you know when it was happening i
was like sure
um but i i did think that it was
not solving the problems the american
people you know and at that time i was
campaigning
absolutely and and the folks that i was
talking to most of them frankly did not
care about impeachment
so because it got drunk it was dragged
out for so long that by the time that it
was like
you know you should have done it in
april and just got it done with and and
then the other part though is like
i would agree with that if you're gonna
do it like do it you know do it you know
after we took back the house and i
became a big supporter of medicare for
all
it quickly dawned on me that it's like
look the democrats control the house
and we can't even get a floor vote on
medicare for all
and it was like wait a second why won't
why won't pelosi put it up for a vote
and that's when again it started to dawn
on me and
you know it was like oh because the
giant insurance companies
are one of the biggest donors because
you'd actually been working your heart
out for
you know months and years to get them
elected and so that would be profoundly
disappointing
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm literally wearing outer known
clothing right now uh because they sent
them to me
and then i loved them and so now we uh
have them as a sponsor the podcast
and then i did something where i just
like went on the site and bought it some
more and then they sent it to me too
you know what i did i actually used my
own discount code isn't that fun
i entered my code yang at checkout to
get 25
off my full price order that's
outernoon.com
o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n-dot-com
use code yang at checkout for 25 off
so why do i like these clothes they're
made well
they're made sustainably so you know
that uh you know you're not
hurting the environment anymore then
you'd have to uh they were
founded by pro surfer and 11 time world
champion
surfer kelly slater so it's got that
vibe you know what i mean it's got that
kind of
comfortable i'm a cool guy
like uh i could be on a beach it's kind
of got that
vibe though it's not really a beach
because like one of the shirts that i
wear all the time is called a blanket
shirt
and it is so heavy that it is like
wearing a blanket where
oftentimes i'll just go outside and not
bother with like a hoodie or whatnot
because the blanket shirt is like
wearing a blanket
so if that kind of stuff sounds good to
you check out outernown.com
use my code yang at checkout for 25 off
it sounds like there was another phase
two when you decided to go from
uh warren to bernie after iowa um where
also
like folks responded to in a way that
also was like wait a minute like
shouldn't i be able to do this like am i
not like uh
you know an autonomous voter and like if
if i decide that this candidate is the
candidate i'm going to support at this
moment in time like is that not
my right like you know i'm not some
raging lunatic or whatnot but like
apparently
folks uh did not respond well even
though
in my mind you're 100 right it was
totally your prerogative
here i'm glad you bring this up because
i i helped
raise maybe like twelve thousand dollars
in grassroots donations for the warren
campaign i was very active in helping
her in 2019
and then yeah after i after iowa when it
was clear that warren didn't have a path
and i was very diplomatic about it i
reached out even to
one of the campaign staffers that was
han that
was in charge of the surrogates for
warren's campaign and
you know i said look like i am proud of
of of my involvement in the warren
campaign
and you know i hope she runs again and
and
and she's ran a great race but you know
this moment in history demands
progressive change and there's so many
you know if if warren stands for
medicare for all and all these policies
that she's campaigning on
you know bernie's campaigning on them
too and now he has the momentum
after iowa and and and new hampshire
that you know he has a chance to really
do this
and i think we need to consolidate the
progressive movement behind bernie and
and their campaign you know they were
well maybe just
you know support both of us and don't
say that you're
endorsing bernie and i was like well you
know like it's my right like like you
just said in a true democratic society
we all get to support you know who we
think
who is the best candidate for the job in
that moment and in that moment
you know in february of of 2020 the
person who was best suited
in my opinion was bernie sanders and so
the day i endorsed bernie and
came out in support of him i got more
blow back i mean
what you said is absolutely correct
andrew it was almost like i
had you know committed a crime on
national tv
i was getting so much blowback they were
telling me i was a horrible person
all because i just endorsed the person
that i think was the was
and i still think would do the best job
as president in this moment in our
history
the the entire warren team came after me
a lot of the more centrists and the
democratic party came after me and it
just got so personal
and i just thought like this is really
ridiculous all because i'm choosing to
support who i want to support
and so in a way you could say that these
more kind of corporate
liberals are the ones who kind of
radicalized me even more when it was
like
they're not even going to let me support
and fight for who for
who and what i think you know what i
want to fight for like
that's just that's not democracy and so
this kind of blind obedience i i do
think and i think a lot of it was from
you know i think that democrats were so
scared of donald trump and just
you know there was all this
fear-mongering that that animated a lot
of people
be like you know but they made people be
like well we just got to get rid of
trump we just got
we just have to get rid of trump and
then but in my head it's like well at
what cost
like and i think that's the
philosophical difference between like
the republican party and the democratic
party
the republican party i disagree with
them on pretty much everything
but what i what i do admire about
republicans is they unapologetically
fight for their agenda
you know they unapologetically fight for
their kind of you know hard right
almost you know white nationalistic
agenda at times especially donald trump
hard line on immigration
you know he's very somebody described
that there was another guy who came on
uh matt jones who's a democrat from
kentucky
and he said something really really
stuck with me he said that
um one thing republicans do better than
democrats is they let
some of like the internal um
[Music]
fights uh take their course and then if
frankly like so if you have like a more
extreme person who ends up like the
nominee
of your party in a particular
congressional race and you're like oh
all right well where is that
where is according to matt and i think
he's right um that the democratic party
is always trying to like
like stick its nose in kind of earlier
in the um in the process to try and keep
um progressives or folks who they think
are
in your mind like unrealistic from like
actually getting the resources necessary
to
um become the the party's nominee in
those races
under the guise of electability but
there's like more to it than
electability and and i think he was
right i think i was like wow
so in that way republicans are more like
lowercase d democratic because they'll
really just let the will of the people
even if the people choose in some cases
like some freaking loons because there
are some freaking moons like
absolutely that are like peddling
conspiracy theories that that have no
faces like you know green and like
yeah but in the part that i'll get to so
while the republicans kind of
unapologetically fight for their agenda
and they fight for their base
the democrats they they they're always
wanting to moderate their message and
they're always
the the democrats are especially kind of
the establishment more corporatist
democrats
you know they they instead of fighting
for their progressive values
and fighting for policies the policies
that their base wants
they they think that they have to
compromise you know their values to win
and what i would say like if you
actually really want to win not just an
election
but win an agenda a for the people
agenda then you don't have to compromise
your values especially while you're
campaigning and you haven't even gotten
to the negotiating table yet with
republicans
you have to fight for your values and
your progressive policies to win
and so i think there's just this
fundamental difference and i think if
you look at kind of
why does america for the last 50 years
do corporations get more and more power
and billionaires get richer and richer
it's because the republican party keeps
dragging us further and further to the
right
and the democratic party instead of
offering like a real
you know economic populist agenda that's
going to bring the country back
and center people in our politics again
they kind of
they run on this kind of mushy middle
and they don't and to be honest
they don't really stand for anything
look at someone like joe biden in this
moment
when when there's this much inequality
and this much injustice
joe biden didn't run on medicare for all
he didn't run on a green new deal
he didn't run on universal basic income
like you did he's not really running on
any policy
he's just running on this kind of
blanket statement he's running around
he keeps saying that i'm gonna heal the
soul of america
you know i'm gonna unite america but how
and here's where you've got to take it a
step further and i know these
uncomfortable truths
you know some people don't want to hear
it but like how are you going to heal
the soul of america
when you're resisting all the bold
progressive policies
that we need to heal the soul of america
i love how you've you've actually
started to try and translate the
platitudes into policies
like i enjoyed a great deal um so there
were two things that that
uh you were discussing or we were
discussing before that i would love to
try and
delve into so the first is
in part because of your treatment by
some folks
during your endorsement of bernie you
said
look at this point i can't even call
myself a democrat i'm going
i'm going to go full socialist you it
seems like you probably changed your tag
to
proud socialist which you know like i
appreciate i love your
clarity and passion um and then the
uh so the first thing i want to talk
about
is how to try and create a third party
because earlier in this conversation we
talked about how like the duopoly is a
problem and if you take like someone who
is for very progressive policies then
they're like well what are you gonna do
democratic party and then you're like oh
snap
um and then you talked about how the
green party was trying to build up and
that
um has not necessarily you know um
broken through so number one let's you
and i talk about
what the heck the the future of the
people's party is and what the third
party mechanics look like
and then the second thing um is that you
talked about having to
try and build both inside and outside
pressure to try and make various changes
happen
uh and i would be curious as to see
where where you see yourself
um what's strange is that you know i
started out as like
frankly like i think pretty much an
outsider i mean i'm just like a dude
um uh but but like now i'm
kind of a bit of like an insider where
like again members of congress
will speak to me you know like like i've
you know like uh um and so i've been
trying to use that to get cash relief
passed
and like i'm gonna keep on pushing for
various things and most people who know
me know that like you know i see cash
leave as one in emergency for right now
because
like so many of us are hurting but i
also see it as a great way to prepare
the ground for universal basic income
because
we'll have like much more data and
certainty and like people will love it
and the rest of it
um so let's start with the mechanics of
the the third
party first well i think actually i
think first it's important to kind of
talk about maybe the strategy
kind of and i do think like you alluded
to
that like i'm a firm believer that we
need an inside and outside strategy
and what that means is that you know
there are
progressives who are with working within
the democratic party who believe that
you
we can change the system from within and
then there's another school of thought
that the system is is so corrupt that
it's
and and because both of these parties
are captured by
giant corporations and wall street and
the billionaire class
that they're going to continue to govern
for and represent
the corporate interests that that
continue to donate to the parties and
continue to give them power
every election cycle and so those are
the kind of the two schools of thought i
kind of fall into the
thought the school of thought where like
if we continue down this road of like
you know look the republican party is is
you know i could never see myself
supporting the republican party
um but at the same time if we're just
going to continue to give democrats
power
and and vote blue no matter who and
demand nothing in return
and not demand policy concessions uh and
demand that they actually work
for the people that that yeah the system
is
uh corrupt beyond repair uh and so what
i mean by an inside outside strategy is
supporting you know the few progressives
that we have
and i i want to applaud your
organization humanity forward
a lot of the candidates that you
endorsed this primary cycle candidates
like david kim
are candidates that i got behind and i
endorsed candidates like jen perlman
you know who just ran great people love
david and james
they're great people they're great
people and they're in politics to
actually
help the people which has kind of become
a foreign concept in washington dc
you know and so and i and i applaud
that's when i kind of you caught my
radar when i saw
there was actually a tweet you were like
i can't remember how it happened but
so for all those out there who don't
think twitter matters like you had kind
of
i think you actually commented on one of
my tweets and and i wrote back like well
would you
would you look at some kind of more
candidates that are not me us candidates
more like
from the bernie side of the party um
like jen pearlman and i listed off like
10 of these candidates and you wrote
back of course like send them to
humanity forward
and then like humanity forward endorsed
i think like six of the candidates
one of them being jen pearlman so i just
saw right away that like you were
someone who
is trying to kind of use your influence
not to kind of enrich yourself and not
to kind of
you know enrich your corporate donors
because you don't have any corporate
donors
but to actually help the people and to
actually like
do good things in our in this country
for
the people who desperately need help
right now and so that's when you caught
on my radar and and i thought okay like
this is this is awesome
and um so again i suppose thank you for
sending those candidates over because i
loved uh
you know anyone we endorsed i loved and
you know like i spoke to any candidate
that we were considering endorsing
and jen freaking phenomenal and the fact
that she was challenging like debbie
wasserman schultz or whatever
you know i was like gary washington
shelters in congress
that was my reaction because you know we
knew her as a former head of the dnc
um uh so that was frankly a pretty easy
call
uh but you know david david kim ran
against an incumbent
um and uh and he got out spent by ten to
one and he almost won
and that shows the the power that the
grassroots has that and there was some
used against david
power you know he had his opponent like
pretended bernie his opponent pretended
bernie endorsed him and stuff like
there's some like dirty crap in that
race that was not cool he did and he
also pretended his opponent pretended
that like he was this big advocate for
medicare for all and agreeing new deal
and universal basic income
when he really just started talking
about those policies more
when david kim was running on those
policies so of course you know the
establishment is always going to fight
back
but at least you know that's the inside
strategy that to continue to build
and elect true people-centered
candidates that are actually
going to govern uh for the people and
get in there and pass policies
that will improve people's lives so i
support that strategy i support
you know the squad and and the few
candidates we have in congress there are
some really nice ways
the status in that like i was very sad
about some of the candidates that did
not win because some of them were
tremendous like i loved alex morris
alex morris is a very bright alex morris
was phenomenal i also endorsed his
campaign
i i agree like let's keep building
progressive power within the party
but there's a butt coming here we go
there's a butt here's the here's the bus
when you really look at the democratic
party there's maybe about
10 or 12 if you're being generous true
progressives
i think even though we've really moved
the
the narrative on progressive policies
and the overwhelming majority of the
american people
now support medicare for all i think
it's almost like 70
in recent polls the majority of the
american people support a green new deal
and support uh direct cash relief now uh
the majority
of the american people support these
these policies that cnn and msnbc and
corporate democrats call radical or
extreme
well guess what the majority of the
people support these policies
now the reason these policies aren't
aren't passed into law
is because the majority of our
representatives don't work for the
people
the majority you know the reason that
the democrats don't support
uh medicare for all is because the
majority of the democratic party just
like the republican party
is bought by the giant insurance
companies in big pharma you know the
reason they don't support a green new
deal
is because both parties are still bought
by the big oil companies you know the
reason they don't support
really truly ending these endless wars
is because both parties are bought and
paid for by the defense industry
and so when you come to unpack our
political system
you see how much power big money still
has
big money is controlling the entire
agenda in washington
and so when i finally unpacked all of
that and i truly like as a lifelong
democrat
it is hard because again in 2018 i would
say well
my political outlook was well the
democrats are the good guys and the
republicans are the bad guys
you know or the democrats are good for
the people
whereas the republicans are good for
corporations and my political outlook
today is a lot more nuanced than that
i would say that court you know
establishment democrats are
bad for the people and good for
corporations
and republicans are good for
corporations and bad for people
and then i would say that like true
progressives are
you know good for the people and that's
what we need we need people that just
want to represent the people and not
these powerful special interests and so
when you unpack the democratic party
unfortunately the majority of democrats
they might talk a good game on cnn and
again spout those platitudes but they're
not actually fighting for the policies
we need
to move this country forward so when you
see that that's when
you realize that we need to also
pressure these parties from outside
of you know we need to build power
outside of these two corporate parties
and that's when i got involved with the
movement for people's party
uh and there actually there's been some
intersection right between the movement
for people's party
and humanity forward that uh and i don't
know if people know this like six months
ago
we were protesting outside of of
democrats and republicans homes we went
outside of susan collins house
and in maine we went outside of mitch
mcconnell's house in kentucky
we went outside of nancy pelosi's house
in san francisco
and we demanded that these legislators
that these
uh you know these congress people bail
out the people
and not their corporate donors we were
demanding direct cash relief
two thousand dollars a month we were
demanding uh medicare for all
uh we were demanding a moratorium on
on rents and mortgages throughout the
pandemic and
and and your organization helped us
spread the word about this event and
again i'm just one of those people who
like when i saw that you were willing to
stick your neck out for a little
grassroots organization
like the movement for a people's party
that to me shows that you're the real
deal because
you actually care about helping the
people you're not in it
i do care because you're a careerist and
you're trying to advance your career and
you're not in it because
you want more power for yourself you're
actually in it because you want to give
more power to the people
and and that might just sound so basic
but like that is really everything
because when you've got a government
that is that is captured by corporate
money
finding real people who actually want to
you know advance
and help the people is rare in politics
i remember that series of events and
like i saw what you were asking for and
i was like yeah i agree with all that i
mean that
end in this case too where you were
you were fighting for the people and so
it was very easy to support you
at least we could do um i know scott
santos who's a good friend of mine
spoke at the event and there were some
other folks too that are friends of mine
that spoke
scott santos was amazing he gave a great
pitch
you're talking about the people's
convention where we held the first uh
yeah that's a different convention and
scott spoke there very eloquently about
the benefits of ubi
and uh what that looks like especially
now that
we're seeing more and more jobs being
displaced by this predatory capitalism
uh and you know scott gave a great pitch
and cornell west was there and nina
turner and it was
it was we had this amazing event and
after the event everyone we took a vote
to see if people wanted to start a new
major party
uh and they voted overwhelmingly i think
like 95
percent and we had like two million
people watch
uh the convention which is a big deal
because they were covered by
cnn or msnbc and you know we couldn't
get any
corporate media to cover it but again
and but i also want to caution people
here like
starting a new party is is tough work
like this is
hard work the duopoly is very very
strong they're very strong
and they're very well they control
everything really like one of the team
controls
and they've been building this power
like i said for a century
uh and so this is going to be a process
we just uh we now file to be on the
ballot in maine
so we're now we're on one state like the
people's party is
is on one state and it's again our goal
is to be on
almost like i think 30 states by 2022
and all 50 states by 2024 again there's
it takes time
to get it so tell the people here yeah
how does ballot access work um
going from 1 to 30 states ballot access
is not my expertise let me be very clear
about that we have
about we have a ballot uh access it is a
thing it gets true
that we work with it's very technical
like every state is different
some states you have to have like a
candidate who runs for governor and get
like one percent of the vote in
other states you just have to get you
know a thousand signatures which
with all of our combined social media
powers
uh but again the idea the and the idea
of the people's party
and building outside of the corporate
parties it's really simple it's
basically like
you know wall street has two parties in
washington and the people really have
none
and so the idea is to build a party that
will not take one dollar of corporate
pac money
i think if you were to really be honest
and do an honest assessment of our
politics
the there's two things i think that has
corrupted our politics the first is
corporate pac money
and allowing these giant corporations to
be able to essentially buy politicians
because remember politicians write our
laws in america
so if you can buy a politician you're
basically getting to buy
access and buy favoritism so when these
laws are written
in our congress the laws when we talk
about a rigged system
what we're talking about is we have
politicians who write laws
that favor their corporate donors and
and and are rigged against
you know the working class and everyday
americans that's what we mean by a
corrupt
and rigged system that the it's baked
into the laws that are written
and so uh that's the first thing that's
corrupted our politics is corporate pac
money and then the second thing is
corporate lobbyists
who now not only do they buy our
politicians they also have lobbyists who
go and
who who corporations pay to go in and
lobby them even more
so so they've they've essentially bought
in them and they have people
in washington who are now getting to to
advocate directly with
our our representatives and get laws
passed that favor them
and a good example of that is the
affordable care act
a lot of people don't know this when the
affordable care act was written
into in 2010 uh about 4
000 corporate lobbyists descended on
washington to write that legislation
and then you got you know so you know
the affordable care act well yes
you know it maybe there was a little bit
of good it did it was really a gift to
these giant insurance companies because
they sent lobbyists in there to get
everything they kind of wanted in the
bill
and it left 27 million americans without
insurance and
we've actually seen you can go look at
any chart since the affordable care act
was passed in 2010
premiums have just skyrocketed since
then and yes republicans have done some
sabotage to it
but at the end of the day it is still a
predatory for-profit health care system
the fact they took the public option out
is really what what neutered the whole
thing
totally and again that happened when
democrats had the house
and the senate and the white house so
here they had you know they had all
three branches of government had a
golden opportunity
and they had a golden opportunity to
like actually pass a public option or
medicare for all
and again they they they they governed
for their corporate donors i'm going to
make a pitch to you ryan
i'm going to make a pitch to you that i
think you're going to be aligned with i
believe
i think that the corruption you're
talking about
is actually baked into the way that
these elections take place
and it goes back to the duopoly issue
where
um so the numbers that have stuck in my
mind
is that congress nationally has a 21
approval rating
uh but incumbents who decide to run have
a 94
re-election rate uh and so the
accountability uh is lacking
um and i know a lot of uh individual
members who i regard as genuinely
good people who want to do good things
but i think the structural incentives
around the way that we elect and real
like leaders actually is another
corruptive
influence that i want to try and wedge
into your agenda
um and i want to wedge into your agenda
because i think that this is the path
to the true viability of a third party
in the duopoly
is having open primaries and rank choice
voting um
i think that if you have another party
in like maine or these other places
it's going to be extraordinarily
difficult if
the entire um certainly congressional
process i mean there are local races
that are very important and we can fight
those out
but uh but in these congressional races
if you have a party primary
like you know the candidate's never
going to be anywhere near it so you need
open primaries and rank choice voting
and then the other big part of it
is then that gets rid of the cudgel
where they can say like look don't waste
your vote you vote for
uh some third party then you're going to
be enabling the quote unquote bad guys
to win
um and so you need to vote for us so to
me that's the big
structural fix that actually will enable
any kind of um uh
modification to the duopoly you're
absolutely right
there's two structural fixes one of them
like you said is ranked choice voting
uh and you know one of the ways these
more establishment democrats keep
staying in office is you're absolutely
right they kind of use this
lesser of two evils argument kind of
like you know well what are you gonna do
vote for them
you know and so yeah it's not just an
argument sometimes
right but again if that's all democrats
stand for like vote for us because we're
not as bad as them
you know like if if the americans it's
not it's not a way to get real change
across the finish line
absolutely if every election and i i
would argue
you know there's a there's a writer i
love his name is hunter thompson and he
argued all the way back in 1972 in one
of his essays
that the democratic party uh you know
they their whole shtick is is by you
know vote for us because we're the
lesser of two evils
that's how long this has been going back
that they actually he says they don't
advocate for meaningful
progressive change their whole thing is
you know vote for us because we're not
as bad as them
i think there was a point in the past
the distant past when like big change
was actually on the agenda in washington
but it's been a long time it's been a
life it has been a long time and i think
if every election cycle your two options
are
are evil or lesser evil how is the
country ever going to get better
at some point we have to vote for good
the whole good point of ranked choice
voting is you can no longer like
it actually matters you rank your
candidate so you can vote for say the
first candidate
i'm gonna vote for andrew yang as my
number one let's say for instance if we
had ranked choice voting
and then and the primary in 2024 and
then number two
i'm gonna vote for you know whoever the
democrat is whoever it is yeah or
say yeah exactly and then number three
is you know
if they wanted to vote for the
republican so it ranks it so like you
you
you actually have to and actually their
studies have shown that ranked choice
voting
leads to more positive campaigning and
and yeah because right now our campaigns
you can't just translate each other it's
so toxic
instead of lifting people up it is so
bad and the whole idea with ranked
choice voting is it actually matters how
many number two votes you get
and how many people ranked you in number
three so you have to speak to more of
the electorate
because you're you know it matters like
where you land you know so getting a lot
of second place
votes actually helps you in ranked
choice voting yeah i
so you should know like i'm going to
want to team up with you and whoever's
working on ranked choice voting and
that's one of our big initiatives for
the people's party but then
number two and i'd say actually more
important than ranked choice voting is
is ending citizens united
oh yeah corporate corporate fighter
public fighters getting
getting the public financing of
elections because even if we have rank
choice voting
if you have if these corporations are
able to just basically buy our
politicians
and someone has you know five million
dollars
in the bank when they're for their
campaign and then the progressive has a
hundred thousand dollars which is
usually how
you know i've had i've talked to so many
progressive candidates and they say the
number one thing that impedes there
is that they don't have as much money as
these incumbents because
you know they have to raise three dollar
four dollar and five dollar grassroots
donations
which is good because they they know
that they're beholden to the people
who've
who rate who've given them who've given
them money but the problem is is when
you get when
you're running against an incumbent who
gets five million dollars of corporate
pac money
they just have the ability to then go
and buy a bunch more media and and
communicate to the public
and then the messages they communicate
they're not telling the public with that
five million dollars that
that this was bought and paid for and i
i'm a corporate democrat
who's going to go in there and give wall
street more power they use that five
million dollars to say oh i'm for the
people
i'm gonna represent your family i'm
going to make this pitch to you
ryan again um i agree with everything
you just said
that money in politics is destroying us
and citizens united was a terrible deal
that made a bad
situation much much worse um and that if
we could
uh end citizens united and have public
financing of campaigns it would be a
game
changer for uh the candidates that you
and i are talking about
the the the reason i'm going to press on
ranked choice voting again
is that in order to amend citizens
united you would need
a congressional control like it's
debatable whether
or not where you might even need a
constitutional amendment because i think
the supreme court ruled that
you know like corporate donations are
free speech which i totally disagree
with
um and so but the the the great thing
about rank choice voting
is that it can happen uh at the state
level where there are 26 states where
you have ballot initiatives
um and it doesn't take that much to get
on the ballot initiative and
it doesn't and we already saw this cycle
it was in massachusetts they just passed
it in alaska
so now we have ranked choice voting in
alaska we have races yeah your old
stomping ground
exactly my old stomping ground so you're
absolutely right about that ranked
choice voting
and then you know obviously public
funding of elections those two things
will help us break the duopoly and not
just when i say break the duopoly
a lot of it is look if there's another
viable third party
where the democrats can't play and the
republicans they can't pit
you know it's not just they can't blame
the other side
you know right now in our politics
nothing gets done in washington dc
because democrats blame republicans and
point the finger at them and then
republicans
point the finger at democrats and while
they're busy scapegoating each other
the nation's problems aren't being
solved and so if we had a viable third
party
no longer anymore you know finally
progressives first of all we'd have
somewhere to go
so the democratic party would actually
have to earn our votes they'd actually
have to work for our votes and they
couldn't take the progressive base for
granted
um you know so that is a that's a huge
part of this too
is just you know again holding these two
corporate parties accountable
um so this is the tricky thing is that
if you are one of the two major parties
how do you feel about rank choice voting
you know maybe not that great because
right now
you can control who gets nominated most
of the time and like
the rest of it um but there's no
principled argument against it
uh and so this is the to me the
opportunity um you can have balance
initiatives in 26 states
plus dc um and there also are
you know you can get it through state
houses in the other 24 states so there
are still possibilities
there are two states that have already
implemented it in the form of maine
and alaska there are various cities that
have implemented it uh st
louis i just heard implemented it so uh
so that to me
is the path this is like the mechanical
problem with the structural problem
uh where uh and it is an uphill battle i
commend you
for starting this effort with the
people's party
because i firmly believe that we need to
have
more genuinely democratic representation
to have a more
responsive dynamic government and
political system
and you know the united states is
somewhat unusual or
almost unique in having just two major
parties like other places like you
you have a more genuine parliamentary
system you have to work if you get some
other independent actors into congress
like they could end up being tie
breaking votes
and have outsized influence and power so
i'm a huge
fan of this plan and i i'm going to be
supporting you in anything that pushes
ranked choice voting
across the finish line in these part in
these uh states
yeah and i would just also add on to
what you're saying is uh you know we are
one of the
in some ways you could call us you know
some people call say that we're a
two-party system
uh but when you really unpack like we
have in this this
this conversation that both parties
essentially yeah there's some smaller
differences between the two parties and
and there's some definitely some
cultural differences
that are that are important but in
essence when both
parties are are beholden to corporate
interests and are working for their
corporate donors
in some respects you know a lot of
people call our government at one party
oligarchy
and and and that's dangerous you know we
need to move from like this one-party
oligarchy to a multi-party democracy
like they have in most european nations
like they even have in canada and in
mexico and and i would add this that
as soon as canada got their more
progressive party
they also got a universal healthcare
system and in mexico the same thing
happened so
i just think that americans need more
choices
we need more choices we need better
multi-party democracy
i co-sign that vision with you ryan
vibrant dynamic multi-party democracy
and if the and if the other parties are
so comfortable in their agenda
then why are they so afraid why why
would they be so frank choice voting
people
let's make it happen um ryan i have
enjoyed this conversation immensely
uh i genuinely like like your your
uh clarity of vision is remarkable do
you have anything you want to promote uh
or share
not really i want to just thank you for
fighting for direct cash relief for the
people i want to encourage people to
keep
you know i know we've all been calling
our senators and our congress people but
you know look i just again you know when
we have a government right now
that is better at waging endless wars
and is better at bailing out their
corporate donors
uh than actually providing relief to
to the people during a pandemic you know
it means we have real problems in this
country and so i just want to applaud
everyone who is
you know demanding better and you know
stop worshiping politicians they're not
there to be worshipped
question them challenge them demand
better from them and when they're not
working for the people
vote them the heck out and get someone
in there that is going to support your
family and is going to support policies
that improve you that improve your lives
you know you can check out my podcast uh
i have a show that i put on once a week
and we talked we had david kim on the
podcast
we had jen pearlman on the podcast we
have a lot of people who support ubi on
the podcast
you can check that out it's amped up
podcast you can get it on apple podcasts
uh or wherever you you stream your
podcasts and uh
thank you for having me on on the show
andrew and again
you know i might be a little more
progressive than you but i want to thank
you for being a bridge builder
you know i do think if we're ever going
to solve these problems
you know one of the things i think the
democratic party doesn't do well is they
just
instead of bringing progressives into
the party and for
for biden for instance instead of
bringing in true progressives into his
cabinet
they keep kind of alienating us and they
keep
kind of pushing us away and i think if
we're ever going to solve these problems
we need more bridge builders like you we
need people that want to have
uncomfortable conversations
and want to bring more people and more
thought
into the conversation so i want to thank
you for thanks man
this opportunity and thank you for all
the work that you've been doing
oh thank you ryan i appreciate it uh you
know i think that most people
want the same things for ourselves uh
and i'll work with anyone who wants to
help people like you said
uh certainly anyone who wants to get
cash into people's hands
uh or healthcare uh into everyone's
homes or towns uh you know um
i'm with you on all these fronts so i
would love to team up with you on that
and
kudos to you really like uh it's it's
been
a lot of fun sitting down and talking to
you likewise
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you